tonight the first indications of how the
federal government will decide
who gets the corona vaccine first and
when you and your family will be
eligible
senior correspondent laura engel reports
tonight from new york good evening laura
good evening you know the cdc has been
focusing all day long
on how they will prioritize who they
deem to be the most vulnerable to coven
exposure illness and death and the vote
happening just moments ago the 13-1 vote
did approve front-line health care
workers and the elderly in long-term
care facilities
as the recommended groups to be the
first in line
now there are approximately 21 million
health care workers
and roughly 3 million long-term care
facility residents
in the united states and while a
significant amount of data was shared in
the meeting today
one thing was made clear on the virtual
call the mission
is urgent this is a particularly
difficult time in the united states i
just noted that
since we're averaging one coveted death
per minute in the united states right
now
in the time it takes us to have this
acip meeting 180 people
will have died from coving 19.
so we are acting i guess
none too soon the cdc's advisory
committee which is made up of voting
members
and several other vaccine experts
determined the phase
1a group which includes hospitals
long-term care facilities
ems and pharmacies along with home
health care workers and public health
officials
will roll up their sleeves first now the
concern by the one person who voted no
was about the safety of the vaccine for
those in long-term care facilities
my concern is there is less
reactogenicity
which also means there's less
immunogenicity two i do not
feel like our safety network for
long-term care facilities is strong
enough yet
i think there's some work that needs to
be done
once the recommendations are sent to cdc
director dr
robert redfield those recommendations
are then going to be sent to states
which will eventually be in charge
of distributing the vaccine and aside
from fda approval
the next benchmark for the vaccine will
be this friday
that is the deadline for states to
submit their request for doses
and where they will be shipped to brett
laura thank you as we told you at the
top of the program the cdc will decrease
quarantine time following exposure to
the coronavirus
this as state and local governments
across the country are imposing new and
tougher restrictions tonight
but in many places the very people
ordering citizens to comply
with the rules are themselves breaking
those rules
national correspondent william lajness
shows us tonight from los angeles good
evening william
well brett you know typically a patient
sees symptoms in the first five days
after exposure
what the cdc is saying here is they're
reducing that 14-day quarantine
period to only seven days for those who
get a negative test
or 10 days for those who have not been
tested at all
as one holiday recedes and another
approaches
health officials fear the worst our
hospitals can no longer safely take care
of the patients
daily us fatalities are on track to
exceed 2
200 a day higher than last spring the
last resort that we have
as local officials at least within my
arsenal is to impose a curfew that will
just
shut it down state and local officials
are at a loss as the virus accelerates
and coveted fatigue
divides residents the county has
their own ideas are right and wrong and
i'm just not
i'm just not in agreement with it this
restaurant in california defied orders
to shut down
i'm tired of people telling us what to
do
i worry about it yes but it doesn't rule
my life
hypocrisy doesn't help save protesters
outside the home
of l.a democratic supervisor sheila kuhl
who called
outdoor dining dangerous and voted to
ban it
then went out to eat hours before the
ban took effect
i eat here all the time in denver
democratic mayor michael hancock told
people to avoid traveling for
thanksgiving
then hopped a flight to mississippi in
alaska a governor's aide urged people to
quote
party like it was new year's eve hours
before anchorage plan to close bars
and restaurants sends a message that
we're getting direction from people that
aren't really believing in the decisions
that they're making last week the u.s
recorded more than 200 thousand new
cases in a single day
yesterday 16 states saw record
hospitalizations
dr anthony fauci expects more so many
states
are at the brink of being overrun with
regard to their capability
of taking care of people in a proper way
particularly in intensive care
now in ohio four gop lawmakers filed
impeachment articles monday
against republican governor mike dewine
for requiring masks
and closing some businesses dewine who
is popular dismissed that effort today
as a foolish
distraction brett william thank you